اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى بايجاز من منطقه
غلاف غزه اهلا بكم لليوم السادس على
التوالي قصف اسرائيلي كثيف على قطاع غزه
وعدد الشهداء يتجاوز 1300 بينما يتجاوز
عدد المصابين 6000 وسط تحذيرات من كارثه
انسانيه نتيجه قطع الماء والكهرباء
والغذاء وبدء المنظومه الصحيه في القطاع
بالانهيار بينما تتعالى مطالب دوليه بفتح
ممره امنه لادخال المساعدات
كتائب القسام تقصف تل ابيب وقاعده رعيم
العسكريه ومستوطنات بغلاف غزه والاحتلال
يجلي عشرات الالاف من المستوطنين من بلدات
الغلاف ويعلن وصول اجمالي عدد القتل
الاسرائيليين الى اكثر من 1300 واستطلاع
للراي يكشف ان
84% من الاسرائيليين يعتقدون ان هجوم
السبت هو فشل كبير للقياده
السياسيه تصاعد التوتر على الجبهه
الشماليه والجيش الاسرائيلي ينشر تعزيزات
عسكريه على الحدود مع لبنان ووزير
الخارجيه الامريكي يلتقي نتنياهو في تلي
ابيب ويؤكد الالتزام بتلبيه كل احتياجات
اسرائيل لضمان امنها في حين وصل وزير
الخارجيه الايراني الى بغداد في مستهل
جوله اقليميه الجزيره تحصل على صور لاطلاق
كتائب القسام سراح امراه اسرائيليه
وطفليها قالت انها احتجز خلال الاشتباكات
وحماس تؤكد احترام المقاومه لقوانين الحرب
والقانون الانساني وجيش الاحتلال يقول ان
حماس تحاول تغيير الحقيقه بينما تراجع
البيت الابيض عن تصريحات بايدن بشان رؤيته
صورا لفضائح مزعومه خلال هجوم حماس ويقول
انها استندت لمزاعم مسؤولين اسرائيليين
الى
اللقاء m